[Music]
hey everybody jimmy carter here for the
part of patrol apparently fred armisen
uh one of the guests tonight is refusing
to come into the building so i've known
fred like 20 years so they said uh pardo
can you get out there talk him into this
i don't know what's going on fred
frank come on man what's going on
hey jimmy hey fred uh
they told me you won't come into the
studio what's going on
is this the studio in this building yeah
the studio is right here the stage is
here man is there a misunderstanding or
are you refusing to come in what's the
what's going on
do i have to go in the building yes
you've done talk shows before fred why
would you think you wouldn't go into the
building in order for me to be
interesting uh-huh i have to make things
difficult you understand okay and today
what it's gonna be is i
have a reason that i can't go into this
building and what's the reason give me
the reason i don't know you don't know
yet i don't know yet it's a wave of
something that i'm thinking i can't go
in here is there a way and i know this
sounds crazy i know the answer's gonna
be no can we do this at another stage
another studio no of course not okay hey
jim that's the that is not jim you don't
even know who that guy is because unless
you've been out here so long you've made
friends with that guy no no no we can't
do it on another stage they built the
set here you're from television you're
not a dumb man what are you talking
about it's not stupidity it's it's uh
it's a request what are they supposed to
tear this set down and build it
somewhere else oh they can do a new set
somewhere else
aren't i you're not steve martin aren't
i why is it on stage 15
well you have a problem with the number
it sounds like you've got a problem with
number 15. what if we said it's stage 51
and the sides backwards does that make
you comfortable
yeah stage 51 yeah he's coming in guys
[Music]